like how have you changed as a man as a
human being as a musician and music
producer ever having done that lengthy
interaction with with mccartney
hmm
anytime you're around someone who's such
a hero
and you spend time with them and they're
a human being
it helps put perspective on everything
you know that they're just human that
well obviously i mean every everyone's
just human and um
but i remember the first time i got to
see paul mccartney play live it was in a
stadium of 70 000 people
and he started playing and i started
crying and i couldn't believe i was in
even with 70 000 people i couldn't
believe i that this man walks the earth
and that i'm in the same place as him
and he's the person who wrote that and
played that and now he's here playing it
for us
it's mind-blowing
that's the voice
that's the i it's overwhelming
is it inspiring
or is it uh
like
because sometimes when you have and i've
gotten a chance
to i mean i love people in general like
every every person is fascinating to me
but
yeah when you've been a fan for a long
time and you meet a person
sort of uh i'll just remove present
company is you um
it's like oh they're just human
so there's both it's both inspiring that
just a simple human can achieve such
beautiful things but it's also like
almost wishing there were gods moving
around us
it's somehow peaceful
this is more uh comforting to know that
there's
you know
there's bigger fish i'm just a small
fish
and then there's bigger fish and they
will take care of the ocean for us i
think we're all capable of being big
fish i don't i don't think that there
are special people i don't think it's
like that
you